us now Texas Senate Governor Dan Patrick
sir thank you for your time um Jackie
Heinrich and Karine jeanpierre went at
it yesterday on this issue and there's a
real question about what the true facts
are on Friday evening just listen to
this Exchange number four guys here we
go the White House statement in plot it
says the White House statement says that
Texas officials blocked US border patrol
from attempting to provide emergency
assistance to there were other there
were other migrants in the water then
why wasn't that included in the other
migrants in the water that's what
our statement is is very very much
consistent with doj filing I know I know
you've this has gone back and forth I I
think the question for today is whether
or not the feds take legal action again
against the state of Texas nothing has
held them back before um why are they
holding back for now or do you expect
that to
change so Bill I think they know they're
wrong they were down here month ago or
so with a civil rights charge with the
FBI saying our Boats were running over
illegal immigrants they watched the tape
in the next the FBI apologize they were
wrong they were wrong about whipping
people you know a couple of years ago
and they're wrong about this these poor
this woman and her children drowned
before uh the border patrol got there we
have the legal Authority in the state of
Texas to protect the egress Ingress of
our property and that's what we're doing
uh we want to work with the border
patrol most of them are good people but
I believe this is a political move by
Biden on down look Bill since he's been
elected president he's had an open
border we have drug dealers gang members
murderers molesters carjackers
kidnappers terrorists rapist that's
who's crossing the border that doesn't
mean that's the vast majority but that's
a lot of the people who are crossing
this border we know we've arrested
almost 300 people on the terrorist watch
list so we have dangerous evil people
coming into this country and Texas has
had it we passed a bill Senate Bill four
at the end of last year in our special
session and it says we now can control
who's Crossing that border it will end
up at the Supreme Court we believe we'll
win I wrote part of this bill we believe
it's stronger than the Arizona bill that
that failed in 2012 and we believe this
conservative Court uh will uphold it
look Bill we've spent I've authorized as
president of the Senate over10 billion
do in border security funds of our Texas
taxpayer money in the last eight years
currently we just passed a budget with 4
billion for border security that we
shouldn't be paying bill that's more
money than 13 states have total budgets
and if you look at the people who have
come into Texas by the time he's out of
office in November which he will be when
Donald Trump becomes president it'll be
over 10 million people that means Bill
the biggest states in Texas are the
biggest states in America by population
are California Texas Florida New York
Pennsylvania Illinois and the state of
illegal immigrants that many illegal
immigrants have come into this country
since Biden's become president more than
any other state except those top six
states that I mentioned this is a
catastrophe for everybody and we've had
it and we're pushing back I have two
basic questions one yes because the
White House has suggested that basically
Texas Patrol officers were negligent in
regards to watching people die will you
take any action on that and my second
question is what it matter to you at all
do you think there would be a material
difference could would you see an effect
if secretary Marcus is impeached by the
house look as far as kamla Harris and
Joe Biden and mayorcas and John Pierre
they're like the Four Horseman of the
Apocalypse you know the last one that
brought death with them all the people
who have drowned in the river who have
been raped who have been murdered who
die in car chases on this side of the
territory running from police all those
deaths are at the hands of Joe Biden and
his administration let's be clear we
lost a national Guardsman a couple of
years ago Dana trying to save he drowned
himself by trying to save other
immigrants we save people from the from
the water we try to save them we
protected this island this border patrol
story is a just a totally fabricated by
John Pierre I'm tired sick and tired of
her lack of data lack of knowledge and
her total lies these people drowned in
the river before they got there we will
do everything we can as we have been to
save people in
distress um we're doing far more than
the border patrol is doing all they are
are Hotel clerks now you know at the at
the local Motel 6 just ushering people
into this country letting them go you
know the question is Dana and Bill I've
been on your show many times talking
about this where does Joe Biden think
these 10 million plus people are going
to go where are they living where are
they working whose jobs are they taking
what schools are they overcrowding what
hospitals are they overcrowding he
doesn't care he doesn't care everything
I said about all these people who have
died crossing the border all the people
on this side the fentanyl death he
doesn't care this is a move by the
Socialist left who want to take over
this country because they believe these
10 to 12 million however many people
have come in remember that's the people
we apprehend we don't know how many come
in and we don't catch turn them into
voters one day bill they turn them into
take I understand your point entirely um
in the interest of time the city land
that you took over I think it's 2 and a
half miles long I believe right so if
you're if you're effectively blocking
illegals from Crossing there don't they
just cross somewhere
else uh they may um we want to make it
difficult bill I mean we're putting
concertino wire up we put the bo buoys
in the water we're building the wall let
them go Arizona New Mexico or California
let it be their problem we're sick and
tired of it here our border bill with
Mexico is longer than the distance
between Atlanta and Portland Maine 1,00
plus miles in Texas with Mexico the
burden is on us we're pushing back we're
fighting back and we've had enough of
the B Administration sir thank you for
your time Dan Patrick let's see whether
or not a lawsuit comes your way today or
not okay thank you for being on with us
today I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and
I'm Angley aart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis